well joined now by the foreign secretary
James Cleveland Mr cleverley it's good
to see you thanks so much indeed
yesterday um he had a speech yesterday
in the hall it seemed to go down very
well were you pleased yeah I I had the
opportunity to set out what UK foreign
policy is going to be much of it of
course is continuity support for Ukraine
the indo-pacific Tilt Global Britain but
also it was about making sure that I
reminded everybody about the need for
strategic endurance sticking with the
difficult international issues
particularly our support for Ukraine to
make sure we send the signal that we
can't just be you know uh outweighted
for uh by by our opponent so they can't
just keep uh doing stuff expecting us to
give up we're going to stick with it
particularly our support for Ukraine
that was one of the points I made in the
speech
you were referring to naysayers as well
you're saying people in the UK were you
know a little bit down on team GB but
you said when you're traveling a lot of
people on the other side of the fence
are very positive who in particular well
I uh the the trip I've just come back
from uh I was in Japan I was in uh
Republic of Korea I was in Singapore
they are really desperate to do business
with us they want to invest with us in
things like green energy generation in
helping countries skip Coal Power and
move straight to Renewables uh defense
and security cooperation there's a real
appetite to work with the UK and these
are countries right on the other side of
the planet and I tell you the same is
true in the Americas in Africa across
Europe
in the asean region the southeast Asia
so there's a real appetite to work in
the US of America I know the US are very
very keen to continue working with us
had an opportunity well you've got to
remember that America is a is a big and
very complex political environment that
individual states have a lot of autonomy
so doing an overall Federal level trade
deal with America was always going to be
complicated but we are improving trade
relations on things like steel okay
aluminum whiskey beef loads of things
lots to get through there were a few
empty seats in the audience yesterday
when you were giving your speech I was
chatting to people people trying to get
back to London and other places because
of the rail strike thought for the rail
workers today well my thought is for the
rail passengers today what I'm saying to
the Striking workers is you've got to
remember there are loads of people not
not necessarily delegates here but I
know in my constituency a lot of people
rely on the trains to get to work and a
lot of the people who get paid only when
they get to work people cleaners and
support staff if they can't get to work
they don't get paid they can't work from
home you can't be a cleaner on a zoom
link so you're saying get back to work
what I'm saying is these people need to
get to work and the real workers need to
help them get to work by getting back to
work themselves okay uh
prime minister yesterday told our Beth
Rigby that she has no regrets she was
some certainly none that she's expressed
to me she is really really cute terrible
start to the conference uh well look
what we are what we are looking to do is
get growth into the economy I am sure
the prime minister is going to be making
that point in Her speech the chancellor
made at that point when he spoke to
conference it's about getting growth
when you've got growth you can fund the
Public Services you can you can you can
fund the support packages to families
looking to uh you know cover their
energy bills and the people that need
our help was ridiculous well look that
program of support and uh um uh growth
plan that the the chance party didn't it
and you've had a good chance so the so
the chancellor put out a package a
growth package which supported people
their energy bills talked about
investment in our road Network to get
the economy really growing
95 of that was ignored and people were
talking just about 40. was people were
talking about the 45p tax rate we wanted
to support well the point I did support
that but the point is I also recognize
that if you've got this wide-ranging
really positive support package but
people are only talking about 45 you
need to get that distraction out the way
so we can focus on the energy bill
support the infrastructure support and
all the tax cuts for 30 million yeah but
it's worth repeating yeah well 30
million that's an item the Home
Secretary yesterday described back bench
moves pushing for that U-turn as a coup
should the Home Secretary be talking
about a coup well the point I've always
tried so the point I've always made is
when you're in government you have a a
wonderful opportunity to feed your ideas
and thoughts in directly to the Prime
Minister and I think that's when you're
in government that's how you should do
it yeah but should the Prime Minister
should the Home Secretary be talking
about a coup well she chose the words
that she chose the Point I've said would
you have shares in that word no you were
talking about well the point I'm saying
is that when you're in government you
have the opportunity to feed your ideas
straight into the top of the machine
it's always based on around the cabinet
table or in the meetings the cabinet
committee meetings that we have that's
how I would do it so she would have she
was wrong to say it publicly well it's
as I say she she
um funny enough I haven't actually seen
the complete context of what she said
but the point is my view is anything to
do with policy or the relationship with
other ministers always better to feed
straight into the to the boss okay uh
what about the chancellor saying the
problem
with the mini budget was because of the
trauma of the Queen's death
well I think
you've got to imagine we we stepped into
our new roles prime minister Chancellor
foreign secretary
literally within days we had the saddest
news possible which was the passing of a
late Majesty Queen Elizabeth that meant
that all the focus of what we were doing
was shifted onto the funeral
arrangements there were announcements
they had made which were which were
quite understanding me quite rightly he
went lost in the moment as we focused on
that and a lot of the discussion and
debate that we would normally have about
the support package and that kind of
stuff we weren't able to have because of
the funeral arrangements of her late
Majesty
um so what we now need to do is we need
to lay out I'm sure the Prime Minister
will be doing that today laying out what
we're doing why we're doing why growth
is so important why we're going to give
support to energy bills and tax cuts to
30 million people and these things we
now need to get to get the conversation
back on today I want to come back to
that but just let me just one follow-up
on that if I may can you really blame
the death of the queen for messing up
the mini budget no no that's not he did
that's not what that no that's not
that's not what he said the point we're
saying is
that when exactly when when when the
prime when the uh when her late Majesty
passed away quite rightly every
conversation in the country pretty much
was focused on that huge and impactful
event which of course meant that we
didn't have the normal discussions
they're not blaming anyone it's just the
story so now you can think it through
properly so now what we are doing is
making sure that they're very well
thought through growth plan that we've
got is fully explained there's a
difference between announcing it and
normally what would happen we would
announce it then we'd do the media round
but explain things we weren't able to do
it wasn't thought through properly no no
it was incredibly well thought through
and the point is it has support for
people trying to pay their bills tax
cuts for millions of workers stimulus
packages for uh low tax growth low
regulations so we are able to discuss
those things in detail now because quite
rightly the period of mourning was about
focusing on her late majesty and new
king absolutely right and properly
that's why so if it wasn't thought
through properly why not you keep saying
that I did well you know he's talking
about the trauma of the Queen's death
taking his eyes okay you're not you're
not listening oh I am it was well
thought through it was a really good
package what happened of course is we
weren't able to discuss it because quite
rightly we paused all that political
governmental stuff so we could focus on
the really really sad events of the
funeral of La Manchester okay what about
support for those who need it uh most
um we were told by Boris Johnson and we
were told by Rishi sunak if he became
prime minister he didn't I don't think
he's actually here at conference this
week that it would be in like the
increase would be in line with inflation
which is about 10
and potentially the other option is in
line with uh earnings which is about
five and a half percent which is better
well what we of course will do in the
normal time scale that we do these
things so we get the inflation figures
out in the Autumn they've only fairly
recently come out we will then think
about all the uh the the needs of the
individuals and the and the groups uh
concerned and we'll be making an
announcement in the spring which is when
we make announcement about uh these
operating or benefits obvious obviously
we recognize obviously recognize that
prices are going up obviously we
recognize that puts pressure on people
particularly those people on benefits
obviously we'll respond to that but
exactly what the operating will be will
be decided
basically uh this year an announce study
part of next year which is the normal
time scale I understand that but I'm
speaking more generally I mean you are a
close friend of Boris Johnson you work
with him at when he was in London at
City Hall you've worked with him very
closely in dining Street he thought this
through he's a smart man he said in line
with inflation yeah he's not prime
minister anymore he is not so do you
think that he was wrong
well the Prime Minister and the
chancellor have got to make decisions
based on circumstances as they are now
not as they were when Boris was prime
minister that's what they're going to do
they're going to look at these things in
the realm that's what we always do and
the announcement the announcements about
various up ratings of of of of benefits
will come out in the early part of next
year which is exactly how they they
normally would well I'm not going to do
well I'm not gonna I'm not going to do
the I'm not going to be the chancellor
today at conference because the
chancellor is going to be the chancellor
in the spring when uh that is the as I
say that's the the normal time scale
that we use he is not a prime minister
anymore but he is still an MP he's an
adventure for now there's quite a few
other back benches who are quite
influential not least Michael Gove
um and those back benches have already
caused one U-turn with this government
surely you should be taking into account
what they think to avoid another
embarrassing u-turn what so what you're
describing as a u-turn
is the smallest element of a really big
and significant support package to
families tax cut to families stimulus
package for the British economy the the
little bit the 45 P was a very very
everything
you guys were constantly talking about
the 45p tax rate which is why we had to
take away so that us guys because you
thought it was the wrong thing us guys
could talk about the uh the the 95 of
that package which was about cutting tax
for Working Families support for people
trying to pay their energy by that point
uh uh giving growth zones
infrastructure investment for transport
which unlocks the growth in the economy
that's what we wanted can I just clarify
with you the only reason that you took
away the 45 P to 40p uh decision as part
of that mini budget was because you were
under pressure from the media is that
what you say no what we said was it was
what we said it was a distraction
because that was the only thing you guys
wanted to talk about we weren't able to
talk about the tax cuts for 30 million
working people the growth zones the
support package for people trying to pay
their energy bills the growth plan for
the country that's what we want to talk
about we want to talk about these
positive things if you've got to let you
go you've got to recognize
we do we do that's true but just to
clarify you're saying that if you have
been picture
that you'd have slipped that under the
carpet and so all these fat cat
millionaires would have got another 50
000 a year that's just what you said
what your view if your viewers want to
know what I said they can just re-watch
what I said rather than what you said I
said and you know what hundreds of
thousands of people will be viewing it
on Twitter as well so let's see what
they think about it it's always a
pleasure thank you very much for joining
us much appreciated thank you foreign